patel's burgers a public nuisance it has
a nexus and a connection to a
disproportionate amount of criminal
activities the LAPD wants to control my
business and run it in their view and
how it should be run and I'm trying to
run it in the view that I've been here
for 30 years and know how it should be
run and I'm successful situated on the
corner of Figueroa and a hundred first
Street
Tam's burgers has been a staple of this
South Central neighborhood since the mid
80s Nick Bennett Otto's began running it
in 1989 when his father retired we've
been in this community we've withstood
the riots when the markets were burned
down and the liquor stores were burnt
down everything was burned down people
had nowhere to go they came to us we
were handing out loaves of bread for
free slices of ham not just being a
restaurant and selling restaurant food
we were actually helping the community
we have much love for the community
obviously the community has love for us
they've been supporting us for years
the restaurant is withstood riots and
bad economic times but now it faces its
most daunting challenge yet a city
government that is branded
a public nuisance the city is targeting
me a small business at the worst economy
ever the things that they're asking me
to do and trying to force me to do would
actually put me out of business
LAPD first approached Bennett Otto's in
2010 and asked for his assistance to
help reduce crime around the area
they said the payphones that you have on
the corner are primarily used for drug
sales and drug deals would it be
possible for you to take them out and I
said of course two months later they
said you know what thank you for taking
out the phones really didn't make that
much difference would it be possible for
you to take out your tables I took out
the tables my business dropped 15%
obviously it's a restaurant people where
are they gonna eat from there the list
kept growing
LAPD asked him to build a fence to scale
back his operating hours to hire a
full-time security guard and even to
install a security system that linked
directly to police headquarters finally
Bennett Otto said enough I don't feel
that they should be able to tell the
business what time to open and what time
to close and how to run their operations
it's hard enough being in business and
staying in business especially in this
economy
our initial goal is to his voluntary
compliance under no circumstances do we
want an adversarial relationship
detective Eric Moore is in charge of
LA's nuisance abatement unit he says
that when a business refuses to
voluntarily comply more extreme measures
become necessary this property now has a
conditional use permit attached to the
land and now by law he has to follow
those conditions violations of any of
those conditions is a misdemeanor
there could be arrest so they could
actually remove the certificate of
occupancy and actually change that use
to where it's no longer able to be a
restaurant if I were to close how much
more graffiti will be on this property
how much more of a hangout would it be
there won't be any electricity so there
won't be any lighting so I think would
be more of a nuisance for the community
to have an empty property instead of a
running business Bennett Otto's appealed
the 22 zoning conditions imposed upon
him before the city's zoning committee
in late November
riots I would ask for the medium
replication the closest thing down here
in all these reports that are in there
from the police department it just if
they can't push me out legally with
which the means that they're trying to
do that they'll just come by and just
keep finding me for the miscellaneous
items to the point where I wouldn't be
able to afford to stay in business any
longer and that's my that's my main fear
you're generating money but your
business is creating a haven for
criminals or in criminal activity then
you have to you know take some ownership
and and and be responsive to that issue
it is true that a number of crimes have
occurred around Tam's over the years
however a quick look at a crime map
reveals that crimes are rampant
throughout the neighborhood
Bennett Otto's says that he's simply
doing the best he can in a sometimes
tough part of town
these are indigenous people to us these
are that we came here we didn't bring
the people here so the business accepted
the people that people accepted us and
that's the reason we've been here for so
long although he's been there for an
extended amount of time we would have
hoped that we could have benefited from
his expertise and that he wouldn't be
able to effectively run a safe business
and he's failed at that with the police
Zoning Board and the City Council
aligned against him Bennett Otto's feels
that the future of his business is in
serious jeopardy being in in the United
States of America I should have that
freedom to be able to run a business in
the way you feel to be run and not the
way government feels they should run you